well if you travel near the strip it's
time to start planning ahead road
closures start next month preparing for
the Formula One Las Vegas Grand Prix
which actually isn't until this fall
Brian will tells us why they're working
so far in advance of the actual event
Brian
yeah good evening Denise and those first
round of track repayments will start on
April 2nd and will be divided into six
parts it's starting on this stretch of
road behind me on sands Avenue and if
you're going to be traveling these
stretches you're going to need to plan
ahead
when you start on sands we go down the
boulevard Harmon then add our Paddock
site itself then Cobalt and we end with
the sphere as Las Vegas gears up for the
Formula One Grand Prix drivers are
preparing for the headache it could
cause I think it's insane because half
these people aren't gonna be able to get
to work on time doesn't bring a lot of
good Revenue but for us drivers it's not
really easy because it's not easy to get
a get around race track preparations
start with a two-part Paving plan
affecting drivers from this spring all
the way through August we bring events
like this to Las Vegas to generate and
build the economy of this city it is a
benefit for everybody who lives in Las
Vegas construction begins on sands
Avenue the first week of April with the
major work starting May 9th closing a
large portion of the strip for 10 days
that will be followed by Paving on
Harmon Avenue at the end of May then
coval Lane in June are taking out the
medians on Harman Koval Sands because
the track goes to one side down the
middle and then the other side so that
they can get ready for the curvature of
the track the process starts all over
again in July with a final round of
Paving the last Paving is basically two
inches of what is the race surface the
racing surface all in all this is a much
more dense asphalt and composition than
what we currently have on the roadways
as for the big question of who is paying
for all this we're told conversations
between the county and F1 officials are
still taking place regarding that live
near the strip Brian will eight news now